Chucky's back with a 21st century
technology upgrade a homicidal streak
and a whole new origin here's a look at
what goes down in 2019 s child's play
and what it all means once the closing
credits roll here's your warning
spoilers are ahead the overarching
villain of child's play is Caslon
industries the corporation that
manufactures the Buddy doll as well as
basically all other electronics in the
film's world a Vietnamese worker erases
one buddy doll safety protocols right
before assembling it essentially making
it evil yep is your problem someone set
this thing to evil the doll is then
shipped to Zed Mart the big-box store
where Andy's mom Karen works
child's play has a little something to
say about smart electronics companies
that promote the idea of all their
products working together the Buddy
dolls can control caslen made
televisions Bluetooth speakers and
electronic thermostats most of Chuckies
killings wouldn't be possible if his
victims weren't surrounded by Caslon
products when Chucky freaks out Andy in
his apartment by speaking to him from
different spots around the living room
he can only do it because of all the
Caslon devices in the room and then
there's also the zed mart massacre at
the end when Chucky uses all of the
stores new buddy two dolls as well as a
fleet of drones as weapons
when Gabriel Batemans Andy reveals to
his friends that Chucky's not following
the rules fallen warns that this is
exactly how quote every robot apocalypse
movie starts
child's play takes a lot of inspiration
from those flicks when Andy explains to
Chucky that he can't kill anyone or
anything after the doll first tries to
kill the family cat it sounds a lot like
John Connor setting down the same rule
for his Terminator bodyguard in 1991's
Terminator 2 Judgment Day
you just can't go around killing people
what when Doreen's fatal trip in the
driverless Caslon car starts going
sideways it's tough not to remember
Schwarzenegger tried in the automated
Johnny cab in 1990s Total Recall and
when Chucky sends a remote-control toy
police car to lead Andy to where his
mother Karen is held hostage we hear
actor Peter Weller's voice come out of
the car with this line from 1987 s
Robocop
that are alive you are coming with me
early in the movie Andy's mom tries to
get him to spend more time with other
kids you said you were gonna try to make
new friends instead Andy hides out in
his apartment buildings hallway playing
on a smartphone the isolation technology
creates has more than just social
consequences in the movie when Chuck he
kills Karen's boyfriend Shane his twin
daughters don't hear him fall from the
roof because they're lounging on their
couch while wearing noise cancelling
headphones the most isolated character
in the film
the janitor Gabe replaces people with
technology by using hidden cameras to
spy on tenants it's only when Andy's new
friends fall in pug and Omar put down
their video games and believe in Andy
that they're able to save him from the
Zed Mart Massacre isolation even drives
Chucky over the edge unlike the doll
from the original films this Chucky
isn't possessed by a serial killer he
truly wants to be Andy's best friend but
he doesn't know how to do it without
hurting people
shortly after Andy becomes friends with
fallen and pug they all watch 1986's The
Texas Chainsaw Massacre - as the kids
watch the carnage on the screen Chuckie
notices how much they're laughing and
how happy it makes them wanting to make
Andy just as happy as the movie makes
him Chuckie grabs a knife and almost
kills pug instead slicing Andy's arm the
doll is genuinely confused afterwards it
turns the old child's play dynamic on
its head in the original film Chucky
actually has the soul of a serial killer
the Chucky of this new child's play
isn't completely harmless to begin with
but he isn't homicidal until children
unwittingly teach it to be by the end of
child's play it seems clear Andy's not
going to be a loner anymore
despite earlier differences fallen pug
and Omar all rushed to save him from the
Zed Martin a soccer producer Seth
grahame-smith and David Katzenberg also
produced 2017 it in the upcoming if
Chapter two
seeing those four friends racing through
Zed Mart armed with mean-looking weapons
is reminiscent of those films the scene
near the end in which the four kids
destroyed Chucky's body also brings to
mind other films but it's one of the few
scenes that won't make you think of
sci-fi or horror flicks instead you'll
likely remember the employees murdering
their hated printer in night
99s office space during the zed mart
massacre detective mike takes a drone to
the chest that was meant for pug and he
warns the boy to run before collapsing
but later when Chuckie lunges at Andy a
recovered Mike blast Chucky with his
handgun when Mike and Karen first meet
there's some awkward flirtation at the
end they lay side-by-side on stretchers
karen reaches out to pat Mike's arm and
gives him a thankful smile there's no
guarantee that this will evolve into a
romantic relationship but it would be a
welcome change for everyone involved one
noteworthy absence from child's play and
possible threat to that budding romance
is Andy's father in the original film
it's clearly stated that he died that's
never spelled out in the 2019 version
shortly after Andy gets Chucky he shows
the doll his sketchbook and
unintentionally comes across a page
where he keeps a picture of himself for
his mom and dad he quickly closes the
book and it's the only mention of the
father we don't know if he died if he
divorced Karen or if he abandoned his
family the fate of the father could be
kept intentionally ambiguous because of
plans for sequels if Mike and Karen do
end up together maybe the father will
return to disrupt their bliss not all
the inspiration for the new child's play
comes from the 80s and 90s there's
possibly some Marvel Studios influenced
too or at least they use the same
shorthand for example Chucky is powered
by a tube with a white blue glow
reminiscent of the miniature arc reactor
in Tony Stark's chest in the Iron Man
movies Chucky's shut down by a knife to
the battery just like Iron Man is taken
out and Captain America Civil War with a
shield strike to his arc reactor and
there's the eyes a regular buddy doll's
eyes glow blue we know that Chucky is
about to do something violent when they
turn red when the Zed Martin a sucker
happens we know he's taken over all the
new Buddy dolls because their eyes turn
red too
it's a visual cue that was also used in
2015's Avengers age of Ultron the eyes
of benevolent robots are usually blue
but Ultron's grow red Chucky's mortality
is only limited by his profitability if
it makes financial sense he'll be back
and the movie paves the way for it after
the
Mart Massacre Caslon CEO Henrique Aslan
records a message absolving his company
of responsibility for what happened at
Zedd mark but also stating that as a
precaution Caslon is recalling all of
the new buddy two dolls the original
buddies are still for sale though and we
see one of these buddy dolls being
shelved along with dozens of others
predictably its eyes glow red before
going dark again Chucky was connected to
Kaz lens cloud Network so as cathartic
as it may have been the kids destruction
of Chuckies body probably didn't kill
him before he could be pounded into dust
Chucky sent himself into the cloud and
transferred to another doll check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]